you and i started talking about this
because i did time mike tyson's
yeah hot boxing hot boxing and um
you were asking me how it was and i
he's very subdued um
you know i i really i love him he's very
very subdued
um but we ended up talking a lot about
pigeons
because he was a pigeon guy that's how
he kind of started he got a fight he got
in a fight
over somebody who stole his [ __ ] and
this first time he ever hit anybody oh
damn
and that's kind of a famous story but
he's a pigeon fancier and i grew up with
pigeons i started racing
homing pigeons when i was seven years
old so was that big because i remember i
went to the spy museum one time in
philadelphia
and they had pigeons that had like a
little briefcase on their arm you know
they had pigeon will have like a little
can you bring that up to nick they'll
have pigeons that even have like a
little backpack on you know and they
used to use them for
spy work yeah they have yes absolutely
and in fact
they used them for well of course they
they've always been
a military asset because they would use
them to communicate you know before they
had telephones and walkie-talkies
and in fact they used them right up into
until world war um world war
one and and they really used them like
if you do it like what can you tell the
pigeon and he'll go you can't tell him
anything but you can the pigeon will
always go back to the first place that
he saw daylight
oh if you if you you know raise a pity
you get if you get an adult pigeon you
buy a bit in a pitch an auction
and a you know a really big homer
classic these days
people pay a million dollars for a good
homer
for a good home or pigeon please they
rate them by miles oh if you're a
thousand mile
bird you know you you're worth a lot of
money
back when i was a kid we would you know
yeah those are called blue bars okay
and those are hungarians
which is the kind that i used to raise
and we would put them in a a train and
the train
with all the other you know we were a
pigeon club and
all the other people would put them in a
train
outside of my home in virginia and the
train would go down to delaware
and the conductor would then release
them all at once and when your pigeon
came back to your coop
you would you would take his band off
and run down to the post office and have
it time stamped and that's how they
would
you know that's how they really races
yeah and so so the pigeon they'll know
so so so the first place that sees
daylight is the place it'll always come
back to that'll always come back
so if you buy a pigeon at an
auction or whatever you have to keep
that pigeon locked up for the rest of
his life because
he if he ever gets out he'll go back to
the place where he was born
and the military like a hot woman kind
of
you know the military they taught them
how to go
to a they would have a little a coupon
wheels
and they would teach them to go to that
coop and they would keep
moving the coop so that the pigeon would
learn to
find the coop going back to a
you know to a stationary barn wow
and um in fact during world war one
the uh they knew where all of the falcon
falcons which i moved to falconry when i
was about 10 years old
is that early to be moving to that or is
that where you like where is it that's
when i found out about it and there
there happened to be a guy who lived um
near me who was one of the pioneers of
american falconry
i read a book about it my uncle was in
the white house
and and i and people were talking about
camelot and i read a book
about camelot by t.h white who is a
british author who is also a falconer
and
he has and that that book was called the
once in future king
he later made it into a disney you know
movie
called the sword in the stone oh wow but
there's a chapter in there
on falconry and i read that chapter and
i just said this is what i want to do
with my life
and as it happened there was a guy who
had been an
all-american football player at uh at
penn state
he lived about a mile from my house his
name was alvin i
and he was one of the pioneers of
american falconry and my father knew
about him because
whenever he worked as a um as a designer
of jets
at the pentagon of jets yeah
he was designing jets and he was an
engineer
and one of the things that um
the state department knew about him
because whenever they were visiting
arab dignitaries who came to washington
the arabs are all crazy about falconry
really that's
crazy about it and that's falcons right
yeah that's falcons so falcon is
i mean so when you moved up to falcons
were you just i mean
i can imagine if you leaving pigeon you
probably left them behind huh
well actually pigeons remain are
kind of part of the sport of falconry
okay
you use pigeons and all in different
parts of sports so
i kept it i had pigeons all in my life
until really until i moved to california
six years ago i kept pigeons
um but i i still have hawks
at you know back in new york i have my
falconry license
out here but i never brought them out
here i got involved in surfing
and you know a lot of other stuff and it
just wasn't as
easy here um
but uh um yeah so i
so this guy i apprenticed under this guy
under alvin i
i'm beginning when i was about 11 years
old
and then at that time there was no
regulation they passed regulations in
1973 and then you had to get a license
and you know i was
i actually wrote the test at falconer's
take
um in new york state and elsewhere to
get their license and i've been involved
in it my whole life
so would you compete like once you have
this knowledge in this so you're
you're learning and like what is the man
teaching you when you learn from the
from uh
mister what was his name he's teaching
you
how to drop the hawk how to care for it
how to treat it when it gets sick and of
course how to train it and then hunt
with it
you're hunting my birds take um
i find mainly hair socks and i've flown
every kind of hawk but nowadays i fly
mainly harris hogs are very easy and
very very fun and they
they hunt in groups they're very
sociable they seem to be
you know what you and i would interpret
as affectionate towards humans and
they're almost like dogs
so when you take them to hunt well yeah
this is because i mean i grew up raising
hands
i didn't mean to be talking about this
no it's fascinating man because
so let's see a harris hall um
i just want to see what this even looks
like and now when you take them to
train or something what do they do
they well when you take them to hunt
with them like okay
you you they're in a cage or on your arm
no actually they'll ride on the back
seat of the car
unbelievable and then and i knew yeah
and then
you knew that i mean i just had an
inkling if i look like that man i'm
definitely
you know i'm not driving i'm definitely
getting a ride and they uh
they're really just like dogs when you
get to the place where you're hunting
you let them out of the car and they'll
usually jump up and
and sit for a second in orient on the
roof of the car and then when you as you
start walking through the woods
they'll follow you and they yeah
and then i use i hunt with dogs too so i
have a couple of dogs who will be
you know looking for rabbits and
squirrel and pheasant and turkey
and when they um and when something
moves they'll chase it
okay so if you see when you're walking
through the woods they'll what just be
kind of going from tree to tree they
know that you're their owner
they're going to treat a tree they stay
in the canopy above your head
and they know that you're going to kick
up game
so um you know they they know
they learn and they learn like i the
bird that i was flying until recently i
had for 24 years
and then every year i would breed that
bird and get some
eggs and babies out of them and you know
those birds are now
all over new york state and all over the
um at least
all over the east coast you're working
at the grassroots level of helping the
environment if you are breeding birds
like i said i you know it was a passion
for me from when i was
when i was really little
man yeah because we i grew up i used to
sell hamsters when i was growing up and
we used to
you know the big ones around us were the
roborovski hamsters we bring that up
nick
um this is in louisiana yeah
and we used to sell hamsters and guinea
pigs or jeep pigs they used to
they eat those down there yeah yeah they
call them cooys
and uh in latin america and ecuador oh
you get down to oh you get down to
ecuador bro you take a jer
you take a gerbil anywhere south of uh
paraguay and it's a wrap
you know i mean nicaragua you show up
with one of these bad boys they think
it's thanksgiving you know
um but we have a different affinity for
animals now i feel like if it looks cute
or if it's been marketed as cute
it becomes not a food anymore you know
um once things get marketed as being too
cute
so you'll get there into the truth it's
not a good food
in my opinion anyhow
yeah and i you know when i when i i
spent a lot of time in ecuador and i
lived in peru for a while and i ended up
eating a lot of guinea pigs
i went to a restaurant i took cheryl to
a restaurant where they were selling
them for food and they had them you know
how the
um when you go into a seafood restaurant
in new england and they have all the
lobsters in the tank and you can pick
the one and they're
alive in there they had one of those
with it they had this
really cute guinea pig house
and you could pick the guinea pig you
were eating and you know
cheryl is just broke her heart i broke
her heart
hopefully it wasn't balanced that wasn't
balanced
well so so very similar to the lobster
in the tank they just had these guinea
pigs just like in a big like kind of a
children's like playhouse or something
kind of little deal
it was a multi-storied playhouse with
little balconies on it
you know it looked like an apartment
building for guinea pigs and
there's no way they look like little
people in there and there's no way that
you would ever eat one of those
but some people are rolling in and being
like oh that's the one yeah that's
amazing man
yeah we never had any that i had i've
had owl i've had some wild meats people
that have
like uh my sister's family will grill up
anything that's dead
so we've had owl we've had like what
else did we have roadkill type
what owl roadkill oh no they'll have
like
yard chicken just chickens that they've
raised in their yards i'm trying to
think of what else that i've had that
was probably
you know kind of unique growing up snake
sometimes somebody i used to work on a
farm for a couple years and people would
kill a snake
and somebody sometimes if somebody had
enough time they would cook it at lunch
um he must have been alligator because
that's on all the menus down there yeah
i've eaten alligator frog was really
you know when i was young it was fun to
give a kid some frog you know
uh at the restaurants they used to have
a lot of uh these kind of singing kind
of they had like this kind of
black group of gentlemen that were like
a quartet and they would sing and then
at the end of the thing they would give
all the kids a little bit of frog you
know it was just like uh something like
fancy kind of restaurant we would go to
like when my parents were having an
anniversary or something but um
but man that's wild though i don't know
i've never met anybody that knew i don't
know how to hunt with a hawk i mean
that's pretty and do hawks have a ar
or with a falcon does a falcon have an
arch nemesis in in nature
well if falcons get eaten a lot by
eagles
and at night there they get eaten by
owls because they can't see anything at
night
and that's why you put a hood on them
because when once it gets dark they just
get calm because there's nothing they
can do about anything
wow their eyes are adapted
for seeing both microscopically and
telescopically during the daytime
and but they're almost incapable of
seeing anything at night
but a lot of the western falconers um
when they you know they hunt sage grouse
and they have to hunt early in the
morning because their birds will get
eaten by eagles when the bird goes down
on a sage grouse
the eagle will see that from miles away
and go down and eat both the grouse
and the hulk man
do you know 80 percent of hawks die
during their first year
they have it's hard for them to figure
out how to hunt
and um they uh
you know only the really smart and lucky
ones survive
a lot of them they have a lot of nemesis
it's mainly owls and
and eagles so you're growing up so you
guys
so take me back also to the pigeon thing
so you would take a pigeon you would let
it go you would put it on a train
yeah we put it on the train and it was
like a pigeon club you were in yes
so everybody have a pigeon they put it
on the train it goes to somewhere maybe
down to the beach or somewhere wherever
it takes it
myrtle beach or something and then they
let it loose
right and then like maybe 100 miles the
really good
pigeons would go two or three hundred
miles if you
you know if you had a 500 mile homer
that's what you would brag about
that's like having like one of those big
marbles that does like a steely marble
wow that's fascinating man so
so now whoever got theirs back first did
they kind of win the contest
i see that's amazing man
i can't even imagine that i can't even
because i think i would not have enough
trust in my heart that i would believe
that that bird was ever going to come
back it must have lifted your spirits
when it got back don't you don't take
him 100 mile away
the first time you do it i i would take
him to school one morning and let him go
and go on the weekends farther and
farther away and
you know make sure that they come back
that's fascinating man good evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could
watch this one or watch this one watch
this one watch this one
watch this one ah